i think honestly my relationship with
religion
um is
was the driving factor
to me and my relationship with
spirituality now
um because i really struggled with
certain aspects of religion um
especially anytime anything is monetized
you just it by nature it's flawed
and you you mean the basket that goes
around that's putting money in it
it could be the it could be the basket i
you know i had a priest i went to
catholic churches a lot when i was a kid
that's all we
i went to catholic church as a kid and
you grew up in louisiana
yeah and there's this one priest that
was constantly you know he'd
he'd deliver a 10-minute sermon and then
he'd spend 30 minutes with a powerpoint
telling you how they were struggling to
pay for the church
and i think that's when it became very
clear and i was like 12.
um but i think that's when i started
disconnecting
religion from spirituality and somewhere
and i was somewhere in the middle for a
long time and then i realized what i'm
trying to find is spirituality what i'm
trying to understand is spirituality
what i want
what i'm craving is a connection
with an understanding of spirituality um
and it's come in
multiple forms and i think from
traveling the world and meeting people
from
you know from very different walks of
life it's opened my eyes in a beautiful
way
to understanding um that there's a lot
more to understand
and that is going to be a lifelong
journey and a lifelong search for me and
i
um and i love the the the
i love the adventure of coming to
understand that and understanding all
the different perspectives
if there's a faith that i don't
understand
i long to understand it as best i can
um and i think it's it's really allowed
me to
to to seek truth and not just believe
i love the uh the religion
maybe it's just because i saw it on
instagram somebody made it up i don't
know i don't care
um but it's omnism which is the belief
is that you don't believe in any one
religion but that there's truth in all
of them
and i think that's right in fact i would
say that's actually the truth in general
about mankind and the human
and the human experience is that at a
fundamental level
the core of what is desired or wanted
or what feels good or what we're all
aspiring to or trying for or reaching
for
is the same so it's kind of like
religion of fundamentally
when you look at the core values of all
of them it's like the same
it's kind of treat others as you would
you know treat
treat others as you would want as you
would treat yourself although actually
the problem is we
treat ourselves like [ __ ] usually like
have you ever listened to your inner
monologue for a second and gone
wow i would never be friends with that
person which is why the real work is
actually the inside job because once you
fix the relationship with the words that
you say to yourself
you start reflecting that back out into
the world and i think that that's sort
of like
and for me that's a little bit where
religion loses it is it's like you go to
somewhere you talk to someone you hand
over your i'm
you're like oh forgive me it's like
forgive yourself
it's like the inside job it's like
you've gotta you've gotta you've gotta
do the inside work
nothing outside of you i mean it can
help for sure i'm not saying it's all
bad
i just think that it's um it's not the
ultimate cure-all it's more
band-aid-oriented in my mind and so
um you know spirituality definitely
is a sort of leans in that do you feel
have you felt a shift from like
towards being more of an inside job
yeah i think you know the two reactions
because i have a lot of friends who are
very very devout in their religion and i
think
uh when we have these conversations i
find it really interesting if you can
remove
the guilt of someone you know
if you could if you can appreciate the
truth of
appreciating truth um and rather than
if if you you know appreciate the truth
about this faith
then that counters your own faith
as long like that's that's where things
in my opinion get
you know you get the hiccup and i i do
also believe um
because because we are seeking truth in
in
as just as humans as people right
um and and there are so many truths
in in all of that and and i have a lot
of friends who are did you say i'm
nism i've actually been looking for the
work yeah i have a lot of friends
who who are that way and i love that and
i um
and i also think that is a challenge
um the messaging
i do struggle with that when you know uh
you're you're
we're you know preached to
about how we're created and how
wonderful
we are and then we're told that when
we're
broken uh we have to go somewhere else
to to sort of fix it and that's not to
say that you know
prayer isn't isn't
i think the messaging is slightly off
you know that
um that other people are supposed to fix
us or
that we even need to be fixed in in
and that sentence is so flawed in so
many ways
um and i i do have a hard time when it's
um when it's when you're made to believe
that you
um that it isn't already in
you and you weren't created with the
good that you're seeking
you know um and that's you know that
that when you are sort of
depleted uh that you have to go to a
place
um i i i think that messaging is flawed
and i think we
um we kind of live in on i mean my
experience in society currently is that
we're made to believe that and that's
not to say that
this is really this is really tricky
because um
because i do believe in asking for help
and i believe in
um you know and i preach like just like
we go to the gym we should be going to a
therapist every week you don't have to
be broken you don't have to have
anything to fix
you're just you're improving all the
things that you have inside of you
there are so many people who have helped
me
um and so many people that i i i need
to to help me but they're helping me
find myself they're helping me
yeah uh see the things that i'm trying
to to see in myself that i really want
to see in myself